[Music]  yes it's been  nearly three hours since that plane  crashed and behind me fire crews and  police are still on the scene assessing  this area  this is a construction site fire crews  tell us the plane crashed right next to  that trailer into a cinder block wall  on your screen there's footage of a  plane in flames  directly after it crashed this happened  around 9 40 a.m after it took off from  north las vegas airport  ccfd says it was a twin engine cessna  310  which can hold about five people two  were on board  after the crash the fire spread to a  nearby trailer where a man was inside  that man is ok he did say he saw a ball  of fire  witnesses described seeing that plane  fly very low  for hundreds of yards before crashing  the faa believes  that they were headed from north las  vegas airport to an airport in the san  diego area  the faa will now be taking over this  investigation we're going to have  another live report for you  coming right up